y
[Música]
el presidente de francia de manuel majo
se vio obligado a ordenar un
confinamiento nacional el cierre de las
escuelas y de los comercios no
esenciales por cuatro semanas ante el
rápido avance de la pandemia del cob y
19 el país contabiliza 4.7 millones de
casos más de 95.000 fallecidos y un
sistema hospitalario saturado
brasil conmemora el 57 aniversario del
inicio de la última dictadura militar
que gobernó ese país enaltecida por el
presidente ya ir bolsonaro la
conmemoración fue ensombrecida por la
crisis política también económica pero
sobre todo sanitaria en 24 horas 3800
personas fallecieron por kobe 19
marcando un nuevo récord mientras que
otras 90.000 personas fueron contagiadas
con el coronavirus
y el presidente de estados unidos joe
biden presentó un ambicioso plan de
renovación de la infraestructura de la
red vial aeroportuaria y ferroviaria del
país por 2 billones de dólares
hayden indicó que espera transformar la
economía del país tenemos los detalles
desde washington
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález estamos en vivo desde nuestros
estudios en bogotá en colombia vamos a
comenzar en el continente europeo en
francia en donde la difícil situación
por el aumento de casos de contagios de
kobe 19 y también la saturación
hospitalaria llevaron a que el gobierno
decretara un confinamiento nacional
atenuado el mismo que ya había sido
impuesto en 19 departamentos ahora será
extendido a todo el territorio
metropolitano por espacio de 4 semanas
las escuelas y los comercios no
esenciales también permanecerán cerrados
por al menos 21 días constantemente
francia ha roto sus propios récords a lo
largo de toda esta pandemia el país en
este momento contabiliza 4.7 millones de
casos confirmados más de 95 mil personas
ya han fallecido y unos 8 millones o
unas 8 millones de dosis han sido
inoculadas estas nuevas restricciones
fueron anunciadas por el presidente
manuel marco en un alocución nacional
escuchemos
debemos frenar el virus
por lo tanto vamos a cerrar en las tres
semanas que vienen las escuelas los
colegios las guarderías pero a la vez
debemos preservar la educación y el
aprendizaje
tendremos que adaptar el calendario de
las escuelas para que los niños no se
queden sin educación sub como bueno y
más detalles de estos anuncios hechos
por el presidente de francia manuel ma
con los tiene natalia ruiz periodista de
france 24 desde la ciudad de parís la
capital francesa
en su séptima alocución desde el
comienzo de la pandemia de manuela optó
por defender las medidas que ha venido
tomando a lo largo de este año y dio un
voto de confianza a los franceses para
poder seguir sorteando toda esta
situación el presidente optó no por no
volver a confinar de manera estricta en
el país pero sí a extender las medidas
que están en vigor en diecinueve de los
departamentos a todo el territorio
metropolitano a partir de este sábado y
por espacio de cuatro semanas el toque
de queda comenzará de siete de la noche
a seis de la mañana no habrá
desplazamientos entre regiones a menos
de tener un motivo de fuerza mayor el
teletrabajo es digamos la regla en la
medida por supuesto de lo posible y
solamente podrán abrir sus puertas los
comercios esenciales en cuanto a la
saturación hospitalaria actualmente hay
siete mil camas de reanimación y estos
pasarán a 10.000 dentro de las próximas
semanas además de esto también habrá
apoyo por parte de la reserva sanitaria
para venir a ayudar
en los hospitales como digamos mano de
obra en cuanto a los colegios éstos
cerrarán a partir del próximo lunes por
espacio de 13 semanas la próxima semana
será clases a distancia luego serán 12
semanas de vacaciones de primavera y se
espera que los estudiantes ya que sea
desde preescolar hasta elíseo incluyendo
también las guarderías vuelvan poco a
poco a partir del próximo 26 de abril
para el presidente macro es la
vacunación la que va a ayudar a salir de
esta crisis 1.700 puntos de vacunación
en todo el país para las vacunas pzifer
y modernas y más de 250.000
profesionales de la salud además de
bomberos e incluso veterinarios que
pueden aplicar la vacuna de astrazéneca
y muy pronto la de johnson y josh
presidente terminó su alocución con una
noticia que puede dar un poco de aliento
a los franceses en este momento y es que
espera que a mediados de mayo el país
pueda volver a comenzar a abrir los
lugares culturales los museos los cines
los teatros y también los bares y los
restaurantes sobre todo en las
de acuerdo con estudios y ensayos
practicados en unas 2 mil 260 personas
indicaron que la vacuna contra el cob y
19 de las farmacéuticas pfizer bayón
tech tiene una efectividad del 100 por
ciento en los adolescentes el estudio
demostró una respuesta más robusta de
anticuerpos superior a los registrados
anteriormente en personas de entre 12 y
15 años la compañía farmacéutica indicó
que con estos resultados va a ser una
solicitud a la autoridad sanitaria de
eeuu la fd ya otros organismos
reguladores para comenzar a vacunar a
ese grupo de la sociedad
de otra parte la vacuna desarrollada por
la farmacéutica astrazéneca en conjunto
con la universidad de oxford sigue
sembrando dudas en algunas autoridades
de algunos países europeos los cambios
en los segmentos de población óptimos
para recibir esta vacuna provocan
también cambios en los planes de las
campañas de inmunización en algunos
estados hasta el momento 7 países de
este viejo continente tienen alguna
restricción de edad para aplicar esta
vacuna otros dos todavía mantienen la
suspensión de su uso por su parte el
reino unido e italia ya retomaron el uso
con total normalidad más romeros nos
cuenta más en el siguiente informe
la confusión impera en europa cuando se
nombra la vacuna de astrazéneca la
gestión de vacunarse o vascular no de
astrazéneca pues es una cosa que no se
entiende porque en el día de hoy en
alemania ya están prohibiendo vacunar
con nuestra séneca a personas que hoy
están llamadas aquí primero el fármaco
de la universidad de oxford y el
laboratorio sueco se limitó a gente
joven ya que parecía ser más efectiva
pero este martes alemania encontró una
treintena de casos de trombosis después
de la vacunación con astrazéneca una
dolencia de la que advirtió dinamarca a
mediados de marzo y que parece afectar a
adultos jóvenes leo el diario cada día
veo las noticias y leo en internet te
vuelves loco intentando entender qué
está bien y qué está mal nadie lo sabe
así que tengo que confiar en los que sí
que saben
y es que cada país toma decisiones
distintas al respecto de astrazéneca un
fármaco que ya ha provocado varios
retrasos en las campañas de vacunación
estatales 7 países como alemania francia
o españa restringen la aplicación de esa
vacuna por edad en dinamarca y noruega
sigue suspendida hasta mediados de abril
a la espera de más estudios otros países
en cambio optan por usar astrazéneca con
normalidad como italia o reino unido-
mientras que las autoridades sanitarias
europeas tratan de restablecer la
confianza en el fármaco
cambiamos de tema brasil conmemoró el 57
aniversario del inicio de la dictadura
militar una fecha que es enaltecida por
el actual presidente ya y el bolsón ar y
también por un sector de la sociedad
brasileña esta conmemoración tiene lugar
en medio de la crisis de gabinete que
enfrenta el gobierno de bolsonaro que se
vio obligado a reemplazar a seis de sus
ministros y aceptar la renuncia de tres
altos mandos militares a esta crisis
política se suman la sanitaria y por
supuesto la de la pandemia del cobi 19
las secuelas económicas que también le
ha dejado a este país suramericano
alva santana tiene los detalles
ondeando grandes banderas de brasil en
la playa de copacabana así celebraron
los seguidores de jair bolsonaro el
aniversario del golpe militar de 1964 un
periodo que el presidente de
ultraderecha ha enaltecido en repetidas
ocasiones pero la reunión de la extrema
derecha generó el rechazo de muchos
ciudadanos provocando choques entre los
manifestantes y algunos transeúntes en
río de janeiro
la gente quiere democracia no dictadura
fuera bolsonaro
[Aplausos]
nosotros estamos pidiendo la
intervención militar estamos pidiendo la
intervención federal con el presidente
bolsonaro en el poder
la señalada fecha llega en plena crisis
del gabinete presidencial de bolsonaro
quien ha reemplazado a seis altos cargos
ministeriales y a tres comandantes de
las fuerzas armadas en la última semana
proyectando gran inestabilidad desde el
gobierno todo mientras el país
sudamericano se enfrenta el peor momento
epidemiológico desde el inicio de la
pandemia algo que amenaza con perjudicar
gravemente la economía nacional con el
índice de desempleo disparado un tema
que preocupa más al mandatario que la
crisis sanitaria
cualquiera puede contraer el virus
cualquiera puede ver agravado su estado
de salud pero el hambre mata mucho más
que el propio virus no obstante brasil
sigue batiendo récords de contagios y
muertes diarias con más de 3800 decesos
en el último día en regiones como sao
paulo han tenido que empezar a celebrar
funerales durante la noche para dar
abasto a todos los entierros
en otros temas el presidente de eeuu
presentó su ambicioso plan de
infraestructura centrado en mejorar la
red de autopistas de carreteras y
también de puentes a nivel nacional el
plan contempla un presupuesto de 2
billones de dólares con dicho plan el
presidente debaten también espera
generar millones de empleos y recortar
las emisiones de carbono y también ganar
el pulso económico a china estas fueron
sus palabras
es la mayor inversión en empleos
estadounidenses desde la segunda guerra
mundial creará millones de empleos
empleos bien remunerados nos hará más
competitivos en todo el mundo promover a
nuestros intereses de seguridad nacional
y nos pondrá en una posición para ganar
la competencia mundial con china en los
próximos años vamos a conocer más
detalles con cristóbal vázquez en la
ciudad de washington
hola cristóbal allí en la capital de
eeuu y que contempla profundicemos en lo
que contempla entonces este plan a
escala nacional cuéntenos
claro el primer billón de dólares irá
para remodelar la infraestructura
tradicional de eeuu es decir se
construirán en cerca de o se remodelarán
cerca de 10.000 puentes y 20.000 millas
en las carreteras de eeuu en este primer
billón de inversión también están
incluidos pues vías férreas fuertes y
remodelación de aeropuertos 100 mil
dólares irá para renovar tuberías para
asegurar agua y agua potable a los
estadounidenses de menos recursos y
otros 100 mil dólares 100.000 millones
de dólares perdón para pues y entrenar a
las personas para poder pues responder a
este ambicioso plan de infraestructura
el otro billón y es donde está la
polémica es también para los proyectos
de cambio climático de economía verde y
ahí es donde los republicanos pueden
poner problemas para su aprobación en el
congreso cristóbal de donde van a venir
esos recursos esos 2 billones de dólares
porque hemos visto que eeuu ha hecho
unos grandes gastos recientemente para
llevar la economía por la pandemia del
joven 19
sí y bailén dijo que está este proyecto
se financiará con sobre todo un alza en
impuestos un alza en impuestos
corporativos del 21 por ciento al 28 por
ciento
los republicanos obviamente pues no
están de acuerdo con este alza pero pues
hay que recordar que en la reforma
tributaria de trump hace unos años
este importe este impuesto corporativo
estaba en un 35 por ciento y pues lo
bajó a un 21 por ciento hay que
mencionar también que en las próximas
semanas bailén va a anunciar otro plan
cercano a los 2 billones de dólares más
es decir en total un gasto en las
próximas semanas que anunciará el
presidente joe biden de 4 billones de
dólares este segundo paquete de
proyectos va destinado a las familias
estadounidenses y entonces pues es era
eso 4 billones de dólares que anunció el
presidente yo beijing en gasto público y
aún falta que haga su curso en el
congreso de eeuu muchas gracias
cristóbal por este informe desde la
ciudad de washington
el líder opositor ruso alexéi navalni
claro en huelga de hambre tras pedir sin
éxito atención médica para ser tratado
ante el deterioro de su salud naval ni
ha indicado que ha padecido fuertes
dolores en la espalda también en sus
piernas y también ha denunciado haber
sido torturado con esta huelga de hambre
espera ejercer presión junto con la
comunidad internacional para recibir la
atención médica que está solicitando
xavier colás desde moscú nos cuenta más
en el siguiente reporte
seguramente estamos ante el inicio de
otro nuevo pulso del líder opositor
contra el cree ming los abogados están
preocupados por la salud de nava lee y
el ahora exige un médico
el líder opositor ruso ha declarado
desde la cárcel una huelga de hambre
para presionar a las autoridades de la
prisión para que le permitan que le
visite su médico personal naval y sufre
fuertes dolores en la espalda dice que
desde hace unos días no siente una de
sus piernas sin embargo fuentes de la
prisión aseguran que su estado es a
pesar de todo satisfactorio tiene por
delante dos años de condena
el opositor ruso cumple una pena de
prisión en la ciudad de pop en la
provincia de vladimir a unos 100
kilómetros al este de moscú el lugar es
famoso por el aislamiento que impone a
sus presos y también por las difíciles
condiciones de vida naval ni lo ha
considerado un campo de concentración
este lunes denunció que se exponía a ser
enviado a un confinamiento en solitario
después de ser apercibido por asuntos
menores como por ejemplo levantarse diez
minutos antes de la hora
y con esto llegamos al final de las
noticias en france 24 siga con nosotros
buenas noches
[Música]